[Musique]
j'aimerais partager avec vous une
nouvelle vision de la connaissance
issu de mon travail sur la cyber
modernité alors qu'est ce que c'est
l'acide et modernité notre époque
d'intelligence collective de bêtise
collective aussi de surchauffe
technologique de connaissances en crise
et de flou persistant et bien nous les
cyber moderne
nous devons nous avons pour mission de
redonner vie à la connaissance à la
vraie connaissance parce que n est
morbide la connaissance elle se fait
lyncher par les secteurs trafiquées par
les complotistes disséqué par des
spécialistes
un peu trop parfois spécialisés elle se
fait mettre en bocal par des pédants qui
la sorte du formol que pour
impressionner la galerie et se fait
couper en quatre par les technocrates
qui la sacrifie sur l'autel du rendement
elle se fait piétiner par les médias qui
lui préfère l'information sans âme
factuel s'enfonce en profondeur de
wikipédia qui l'a saucissonne jusqu'aux
formations en ligne qui l'a brad en
passant par les communicants qui l'a
désincarné la vraie connaissance agonise
nous devons la sauver lui redonner du
corps du souffle des couleurs est
d'abord lui redonner vie
la vie la vie s'épanouit dans la
luxuriance à la façon d'une jungle plus
il ya diversité mieux elle se porte plus
elles prolifèrent et ce fait se vérifie
aussi bien à l'échelle macroscopique que
microscopiques et aussi bien avec la vie
biologique qu'avec la vie des idées on
sait par exemple que l'effondrement de
la biodiversité met en péril un
écosystème et que pour la santé de
l'environnement c'est-à-dire pour notre
survie
nous devons protéger la biodiversité est
d'abord la protéger de nous mêmes et
bien c'est un peu la même chose dans
notre tube digestif
on y trouve des dizaines de milliers de
milliards de micro organismes des
bactéries des champignons et même des
virus et même de la corona cherchez
l'intrus
une petite note d'humour ça ne fait
jamais de mal
revenons à nos champignons là à
l'intérieur tout une jungle grouillante
de vie une flore et une faune
intestinale qui se développe
progressivement après notre naissance il
y à 150 fois plus de gènes dans le
microbiote intestinal que dans le cas de
gêne dans le génome humain un être
humain saint vit en symbiose avec ces
bactéries des bactéries qu'ils aident à
digérer qui lui fabrique des vitamines
qui le protège des maladies qui agissent
sur son cerveau et ses humeurs
hier on les combattaient à grand renfort
d'antibiotiques
aujourd'hui on les bichonne on apprend à
les traiter comme des autres avec
lesquels vivre en bonne intelligence
on nous promet que la prise en compte de
notre capital bactérien va révolutionner
la médecine probiotiques manipulation
alimentation transplantation fécale
oui bouffer de la merde monsieur oui là
on parle de médecine alors on va mettre
un peu les formes quand même je sais pas
greffe de sel 1 fécales aux thérapies
médicaments passons
je ne suis pas venu vous parler du
microbiote je suis venu vous parler du
logo biot la jungle d'idées de croyance
de récits que nous avons dans notre
cerveau le logo biot alors le cerveau je
devrais dire notre premier cerveau parce
que certains appellent le microbiote le
deuxième cerveau de fait par le nerf
vague
ces deux univers sont physiologiquement
relier le logo biot donc deux bios la
vie et logos
la raison la passion venant excusez moi
la raison la parole le discours humain
logo ça donne le suffixe logis vous
savez pour parler d'une science ou d'une
étude à prétention scientifique comme la
muséologie l'art de la conservation et
de la présentation des oeuvres où la
mixologie l'art de la conservation et de
la présentation des cocktails donc le
logo biot qu'est ce que c'est toute une
jungle de souvenirs d'intuition de
croyance de crainte d'espoir
d'hypothèses de certitudes de fantaisie
de fiction d'abstraction qui grouille et
prolifèrent dans notre tête et ça fait
un paquet un paquet d'événements vécus
digérer pendant le rêve puis intégré
dans notre mythologie intimes sous forme
de narration
parce que notre cerveau est tout juste
bons à se raconter des histoires oui ça
fait un paquet un pack a de quoi un
paquet de los boys longueuil le pluriel
de logos qu'est ce que c'est et
longueuil les longueuil ce sont des
bribes de sens des petites briques sub
narrative images impression odeurs mot
parfum émotions qui prise isolément ne
nous disent pas grand chose mais en se
combinant en s'agrégeant les unes aux
autres comme des briques de lego forme
des symboles des idées des savoirs le
logo légaux mémo techniquement on est
bon donc notre connaissance n'a rien à
voir avec une étagère bien rangé c'est
la jungle
sas ces vivaces ces sauvages c'est
darwin escaut possible des idées s'y
livrent bataille sans état d'âme et même
les souvenirs
en apparence les plus domestique et
s'échappe déborde se mélangent
forniquer font des petits si bien que je
ne peux pas vraiment contrôler ce que je
pense c'est plutôt ce que je pense ou ce
qu'ils pensent en moi ce qui me fait
penser qu'ils me contrôler j'essaie tout
au plus de nourrir la bête de la
primaube le de l'approvisionner de
l'apprivoiser aussi ou si la bête
m'importune de lui couper les vivres et
de la laisser crever je sais c'est cruel
mais il y à des bêtes immondes qui vous
polluent le jugement qui vous font
croire que la terre est plate
chivu radicalise qui vous fans attise
qui sèment la désolation dans votre for
intérieur et dégradent votre logo biot
de façon irrémédiable plus mon
microbiote est riche plus il protège ma
santé physique plus mon logo biot est
riche plus il protège ma santé psychique
mais le microbiote et le logo biot sont
reliés comme je voulais dit par le nerf
vague le nerf pneumogastrique la la
fibre nerveuse la plus la plus longue du
corps qui relie dans les deux sens
le cerveau à la plupart des organes
essentiels dont l'intestin microbiote
logo biot microbiote ça circule je pense
donc je suis la connaissance c'est un
logo biot un écosystème interne un
écosystème voilà notre nouveau paradigme
on dit que les vieux d'okinawa
deviennent centenaire parce qu'ils
mangent des légumes et font de
l'exercice key mais la raison de leur
bonne et longue santé c'est surtout
qu'ils sont très entourées il conserve
ainsi une activité logo biotique intense
un échange un échange de logo riche et
continue une fraîcheur d'esprit qui
déteint sur leur corps à tous les âges
de la vie
enrichir notre portefeuille affectif
c'est enrichir notre âme
bonjour résume le microbiote c'est la
jungle foisonnante et intime de notre
corps le logo biot c'est la jungle
intime et foisonnante de notre esprit
alors évidemment dans ces cas là on voit
à peu près ce que ça veut dire se
cultiver se mettre en contact de
nourritures intellectuelles stimulante
on comprend dans ce cas-là ce qu'est la
pédagogie l'art d'ensemencer le logo
biot plus je développe cette jungle
intérieur plus je dois soigner ma logo
diversité la logo diversité d'un
individu se soigne en n'allant à prendre
dans hors des sentiers battus en ouvrant
ses horizons avec un vrai amour de l'art
mix ofili à ne pas confondre avec la
mixologie et puis on peut avoir une
échelle sociale la logo diversité d'un
groupe
on comprend alors que le logo biot est
un acteur essentiel de la santé culturel
d'une communauté d'une nation voire même
d'une civilisation
je suis convaincu qu'en adoptant cette
vision dynamique et organique de la
connaissance
nous pouvons sortir de la culture
fossilisés conjuguer l'apprentissage
avec la gourmandise nourrir nos
aspirations démocratiques écologique et
humaniste nous venons de tourner la page
des années 2010 qui ont vu la cyber
modernité et clore avec les smartphones
les blogs les réseaux sociaux
laissez-les filet fake news la poste
vérité on débat on apprend on critique
comme jamais on s'insulte et on se
menacent aussi comme toujours plus
l'envoûtement numérique menace
plus l'intelligence artificielle singes
l'humain plus nous devons faire
prévaloir les droits sacrés de notre
logo biot des nourritures
intellectuelles vivifiante
une édification stimulante des échanges
si fertile qu'ils font buggé la machine
il incombe à chacun d'entre nous de
soigner le logo biot humain vous avez
compris c'est bon je le logo biot est en
vous cette drôle d'idée farfelues et a
toujours évidemment quelques rares
philosophes français qui ont flirté avec
une idée similaire
enfin quand je dis flirter on n'est pas
dans le french kiss non plus ils ont
juste effleuré cette idée je cite
condillac traiter des sensations le
jugement la réflexion les passions
toutes les opérations de l'âme ne sont
que la sensation même qui se transforme
différemment et en 1802 cabanis dans les
rapports du physique et du moral de
l'homme
oui cabanis non c'est pas assez pas de
l'humour là c'est juste son nom en fait
je cite cabanis cabanis le cerveau
digère pour ainsi dire les impressions
il fait organiquement la sécrétion de la
pensée cavani c'est chris n ya plus de
deux siècles
on s'est beaucoup moqué de lui à
l'époque de sa comparaison du cerveau et
de l'estomac et bien la théorie du logo
biot lui donne un peu raison mon cerveau
grâce au logo biot va digérer mon vécu
et secret tu es ma pensée plus mon logo
biot se raréfient plus mon logo biot
s'atrophie plus la diversité diminue
mais plus je suis exposé à des risques
pour ma santé intellectuelle intérêt
limité énergie bête obsession
désoeuvrement
nous devons
soignée et enrichir notre logo biot
c'est le message que j'avais envie de
faire passer et puis un peu l'idée
j'avais envie de vous faire passer et
vous avez compris en quoi même pas 15
minutes
cette drôle d'idée est en vous désormais
vie en vous alors imaginez le nombre de
lots golconde ingurgite en lisant en
lisant un bon livre une technologie logo
biotique qui a fait ses preuves
imaginez le nombre de lots boy kong
urgent it en suivant une formation
aspirante fondée sur une éducation non
plus concurrentiel mais complice ou les
apprenants centraide et son courage
imaginez le nombre de l'orgueil qu'on
ingurgite en ayant une bonne et longue
conversation sans téléphone sans écran
sans notes sans rien juste l'autre mois
ou deux
nos mots nos fragilités nos présences
nos sentiments nos jungle à jardiner ça
la culture
nolan nos mémoires animal nos gestes nos
masques nos regards
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée au
cours d'un french kiss de 10 secondes
je vous parle d'une pratique que l'aîné
après le coronavirus ne pourront pas
connaître au cours d'un french kiss
digne de ce nom 80 millions de bactéries
sont échangés oui dans les deux sens 80
millions traduction plus nous nous
embrassons plus nous échangeons nos
microbiote plus nous philosophons plus
nous échangeons nos logos biot
hybridation bactériologique hybridation
intellectuelle au fond si nous voulons
vraiment changer le monde nous devons
beaucoup nous embrasser et beaucoup
philosopher pas en même temps aller
pourquoi que quoique bon alors pour
finir en beauté un petit exercice
avec vos deux voisins et voisines un
french kiss ou philosophie c'est vous
qui voyez
enfin vous mettez d'accord 1 quand même
c'est bon et surtout n'oubliez pas une
petite pointe d'humour ça fait jamais de
mal
vous êtes fin prêt à les bonbons
hybridation les amours arnautu peut
éteindre un peu d'intimité
[Applaudissements]